this video is the Schrodinger equation
part two so if you haven't seen it you
might want to watch part one here first
on the other hand if you're just here
for me to explain the derivation of the
equation and how to use it stick around
okay
so if it was your task to build a new
theory of physics you'd need to decide
what things are so fundamental that you
should build them into the theory
conservation of energy is probably high
up there on your list as it clearly was
on Schrodinger's because that principle
is baked right into quantum mechanics
via the Schrodinger equation suppose we
have a particle with this wave function
at the start remember we can write our
state in any basis we want so a
perfectly valid one is the energy
eigenbasis this means we can always
write a state as a superposition of
different energies and remember if we
measure the energy of that particle it
will just be one of those with this
probability now say this state evolves
in time in other words we apply the time
evolution you what condition do we want
to impose on the new energies of the
state in other words how do we want
conservation of energy to look like in
quantum mechanics first let's look at
the special case where a particle just
has one energy e when we start in other
words it is an energy eigenstate then we
evolve it forward in time and look at
the energy of the new state now we
definitely want that to be e because
otherwise energy is definitely not
conserved so that's the first thing
we'll require but will require more
going back to the general case if we
looked at the average energy of the
particle that also shouldn't change
after some time because if on average
the energy has increased I don't think
we'd be willing to say that the energy
of this particle was conserved either in
fact let's ask for even more from
conservation if we were to measure the
particles energy initially you have this
probability of measuring this energy
well let's require that if instead you
measured it afterwards you have the same
probability of getting that energy you
can't tell the
difference between the two states by
measuring energy this requirement is
pretty much strong enough to give us the
Schrodinger equation as we'll see we can
always write the final state as a
superposition of energies just because
we can do that with any state but we
can't have another energy in here that
wasn't in the original that would mean
that there was a zero chance of
measuring that energy originally but
later that chance was not zero we just
need to know about how the coefficients
have changed in the new one we want the
probabilities to be the same but that
probability is just the length of this
complex number squared so this number
here better have the same length let me
draw this complex number as an arrow for
a second then this complex number here
is the same length but it might be
rotated let's call this angle of
rotation theta there's a convenient way
to represent rotations that we've seen
before this equation says that the new
coefficient is the old one rotated by an
angle theta okay so let's put all of
these in for all of the energies great
now we're almost done two little things
though first these can't all have been
rotated by the same amount
why because then this rotation can be
brought out to the front and now both
the future and present state are
essentially the same that's because this
overall rotation here doesn't affect any
measurement outcomes but that would mean
that no matter what crazy situation you
put the particle in it does nothing so
that's not right so the only solution is
to make sure that these angles here are
different for every energy also the
amount of rotation should depend on how
much you've gone forward in time so that
if you've only gone forward a little bit
you've only rotated a little bit that
suggests that the right amount of angle
to rotate by is energy times time oh and
throw in some constant there to deal
with units and scaling and all that and
we're done that's what the Schrodinger
equation tells you will happen to the
state
talk a little bit about using it now say
that we start with this state where this
energy is twice as big as the lowest
energy and the next is three times this
big and these are their coefficients as
you evolve it in time the second one's
angle changes twice as fast and the
third one
three times as fast but regardless you
might be thinking that these states
hardly look different and that's kind of
right in this basis but if you look in
another basis the difference can be much
more obvious for example suppose that in
the position basis each of these had
wave functions that looked like this
then at the very start when you add them
up the probability of finding the
particle at various points looks like
this but see how that evolves in time to
give a probability distribution that
changes dramatically the reason is these
complex numbers at the start they all
just add like normal to give you this
but later in time when these complex
numbers are pointing in different
directions they don't just add up
anymore as an extreme example if these
two arrows pointed in opposite
directions this would mean that they
subtract from one another this is why
the overall wave function in the
position basis can vary so much over
time so that depending on the time you
measure the particle might have a very
big probability of ending up here versus
here instead yet if you measure energy
you always get one of these three
energies with these probabilities no
matter what time it is this is in
general true things look pretty calm and
unchanging for measurements of energy
but they can look very very different
when measuring something else and that's
it everything that you need to know
about the Schrodinger equation okay just
kidding there's one last bit to it and
it yeah it's kind of a big deal how do
we know what the energy eigenbasis is if
we take an energy eigen vector how do we
find out what it looks like in the
position basis well thankfully
Schrodinger also gave us an equation
that defy
what an energy eigenstate is and it's
what you'd expect as well the issue is
this equation is spectacularly hard to
solve by that I mean it's probably
impossible to solve it mathematically
for just about anything bigger than two
particles you just have to resort to
doing it by computer preferably the
supertype that's why physical chemists
do so much hard work on the Schrodinger
equation and it's something that I feel
completely under qualified to talk about
since as physicists we tend to put these
problems into the too hard basket maybe
if I do learn it one day we can come
back to it but let's for now move along
to homework time first throughout these
two videos I kept talking about
predicting the future and that if you
know the present state you can predict
the future state does this mean that
quantum mechanics is deterministic if
you don't think so comment on where the
determinism ends and the randomness
starts in this theory so can show that
for the Schrodinger equation this is
true that it's the same thing to go
forward in time t1 plus t2 as to go
forward in time t1 and then go forward
in time t2 this seems obvious but
explain what the philosophical
consequences of this might be third I
said that linearity follows from the
Schrodinger equation can you see why try
and prove it please type your answer in
the comments but afterwards you can
click this link for a video of a short
proof of it yours will likely be a
little bit different though so I think
it's really interesting and helpful if
you write down your answers first and
fourth this is for people who've done
quantum mechanics before and know that
in this theory time evolution is unitary
yet I just went on about linearity so
much in the previous video show that
linearity plus the assumption that time
evolution Maps valid States to other
valid States is equivalent to saying
that evolution is unitary I'll put the
proof of that in the video there as well
so sorry these videos and my replying to
comments has been so haphazard lately as
you might know I started my PhD recently
and I'm finally settling into it so
hopefully I'll be a little bit more
consistent from now but more about that
soon